[Music]
when you're one in five are you and just
trading away a guy of that caliber
does it make you think man we're giving
up
i mean
i don't even know how to answer that but
i'm sorry yeah yeah yeah but uh no it
you know if i if i knew how to run a
team i'll be running you know what i
mean you know i can sit here and say my
opinion on a lot of things but um you
know i don't know what what plans they
have for us upstairs like that and
you know it's the name of the business
that's jalen richard of the oakland
raiders addressing reporters yesterday
and if you're watching on nbcsn you may
have noticed hanging in the lockers
behind him i saw a chargers jersey and a
dolphins jersey i guess with so many
guys being traded they just keep their
new jerseys on hand peter so you know
hey if you're if you're gone eventually
here you go here's your new team
mike at least at least jalen richard
didn't go to the jalen ramsey quote
after the game because the jalen ramsay
quote board jaylen ramsey would have
said hey i i can't tell you what's going
on in here but look nudge nudge wink
wink you all know the problem is blake
bortles
you know and and
you know obviously everybody in that
oakland locker room thinks of course
we're giving up on this year we're
playing for next year now i will say
this i think oakland did well in that
trade you know to get a one for a guy
who over the last year and a half
whatever it is 22 games you know has not
been a number one receiver
and and to me i don't know what the
issue is you hear all kinds of stories
out of oakland does he love football
uh does he really fight for the football
is he gonna be one of those guys one of
those gruden grinder guys i mean those
are the kind of things that you start
hearing out of oakland but then again i
mean khalil mack would have been a
gruden grinder type guy and he let him
walk
yeah but with cooper you're right peter
he hasn't performed like a number one
receiver and i think to get a first
round pick for him at a time when you
are clearly rebuilding makes a ton of
sense it's just another potentially
talented player that the raiders will
take into las vegas they have three
first-round picks now in 2019 and
clearly they have given up on this
season and i was i don't know is it
stunning i was i'd like to get your
reaction i was somewhere between
surprised and stunned that the players
weren't told about the trade by john
gruden himself that they found out on
their phones and then he won't even
address them about the trade until
wednesday it seems like you could plan
it out a little bit better so the coach
can break the news to the players and at
least get a talking point or two out
there that you hope that maybe the
players will repeat when when being
questioned by reporters
well i think the problem there is you're
coming off your bye week and
there's
there's really not any way in my opinion
anyway that they could have done it any
differently for a very simple reason you
know the cowboys aren't going to keep
this under wraps for
x number of hours i mean the only way
you could have done something is if you
sent a mass text a group text to your
players and explain to them why you did
this
but then somebody's going to leak the
text to the press and you know i don't
know i don't think they really could
have done it any differently i do think
this going forward look the dallas
cowboys clearly have not
have said that
we want to give our young quarterback
every chance there's nobody that's very
good in this division this year we just
got officiated maybe out of an overtime
and maybe a win in washington
uh with the bad call in my opinion a
horrendous call
at the end of regulation you know on the
uh on the snap penalty you know on the
long snapper and the cowboys have to be
thinking that we can win this division
so we are all in this year hey good for
them i think they overpaid for for
cooper but they're trying
well but i also think peter they are
walking into a situation where there
will be a ton of pressure on this team
endless questions about amari cooper are
you using him enough why isn't he
getting the ball how does he fit into
the offense and this is the point i made
about dez bryant as he continued to wait
and he's still waiting to join a new
team when you have a new team it's a new
city it's a new coaching staff it's a
new playbook it's new terminology it's a
new quarterback it's new teammates it's
the equivalent of changing the tire on a
moving car if you try to do this during
the season and the pressure is going to
be there because it's the cowboys with
all those high-profile games with all
the reporters covering the team where's
amari cooper why aren't they throwing
omari cooper and is that going to affect
dak prescott when he's trying to make
decisions about what to do with the ball
you know one of the arguments we heard
about how dak can be better this year is
he doesn't have to worry about placating
dez bryant jason whitton now he's got to
worry about placating amari cooper and
everyone out there who will question why
aren't you getting the ball to amari
cooper
and look mike here's here's the other
thing i would say about cooper you know
the
the
he's going to be getting all these
questions the cowboys are going to be
getting all these questions and i just
want you to think of this
you know i'm going to tell you a couple
of the receivers now who've caught more
balls than amari cooper since opening
day 2017.
jermaine curse who switched teams
and went to a team that doesn't throw
the ball
adam humphries of the tampa bay
buccaneers nobody even knows who adam
humphries is he's a wide receiver who's
caught more passes than amari cooper
ryan grant has caught more passes you
know than amari cooper my only point is
is simply this he's caught 70 balls in
the last year and a half and you're
putting him in a position now where
everybody is going to expect him to be
julio jones jr
if you're getting traded for a one and
you're coming in to be the number one
receiver on america's team the focus is
going to be uber
over what it was in oakland and in
oakland they already were trying to get
him the ball all the time so there is
the the problem that you're talking
about mike
but and i'd love to know and maybe we'll
find out in time some of the inner
discussions that happened with the
cowboys as to whether or not to go
through with this it was very curious
that jerry jones avoided reporters after
the game on sunday out of character for
jones to have nothing to say he had
cancelled his tuesday appearance on
105.3 the fan in dallas in advance of
the trade and now the trade's done it'd
be interesting to see if he goes ahead
and goes through with it unless there's
something else he's trying to keep under
wraps but i i just i can't imagine that
everyone was on the same page that it
makes sense to give up a first-round
pick for a guy who may not be a number
one receiver and this is going to
complicate jason garrett's life going
forward as he tries to coach this team
let's keep talking about this amari
cooper trade from the raiders to the
cowboys we've got plenty more pft live
to come and i want to look at it also
from the financial angle because amari
cooper's got a 13.9 million dollar
salary for next year and when it's time
to sign into a contract it can get very
expensive hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports